hey guys just waiting for some people to
come in yeah it's just waiting how you
doing
there's some news that we got to talk
about some pretty serious news we got to
talk about a Marvel fan boy is pissed
okay was his wait till a few more people
in here and then we'll uh well dive into
the two main stories and then I got a
jet but put some move some things around
to make sure we could cover this but man
this is crazy Brian I will I will be on
you McHale how you doing Michael Tony
Talley
quits Lerner sad now all right so once
we got this set up can you guys hear us
so can you guys hear me okay don't worry
John's right here I know right it's kind
of weird at matrix floor it gets and
gets announced matrix for gets announced
and it's like oh that's some cool news
you get the Bond title and then you
Emily all right matrix for whoa that's
crazy and then suddenly this Spiderman
[ __ ] comes out and you're like what the
hell's going on the neighbor and
everyone's making money moves today so
John in case people don't fully grasp
some of it you want to give some I feel
like you might be better at explaining
some basics of what's been going on so
like
marvel's only gone in a small mario
start with marvel then we'll move on to
matrix okay so the best of my limited
understanding is that with these
spider-man homecoming far from home and
appearance in Civil War moments in the
spider-man current film series Marvel
has only been making money off the first
day ticket sales which is a lot but not
much compared to what the movies
probably raked back in and arguably what
they deserve to make oh yeah for the
course correction that has happened with
that series since they came in so yeah
what Sony wanted to do was stick with
that deal what Marvel wanted to do is
basically co-produce 50/50 on those
movies
thus basically giving them a bigger
stake in them arguably more control in
them Sony was not about that and we
haven't heard if there's been any kind
of
counteroffer of any varieties so right
now it certainly sounds like the Marvel
involvement with spider oh and they also
wanted further or potential further
involvement in the other spider-man
universe movies that's like venom things
like that yeah so yeah nobody went for
either of those yet well I bet there's
some behind-the-scenes talk that went
down with having some Marvel some more
MCU characters for to cross paths so
that way they could get venom into some
MCU films or their spider-verse movies
whatever they can do to get cross in it
there okay so I feel like there's two
sides of the argument here most like
that are gonna occur this news is pretty
fresh so I don't know exactly what it is
one side's gonna say Sony's being greedy
and other side's gonna say Disney's
being greedy
what so for because let's face it
spider-man would not be reinvigorated
and revitalized and is what it is now if
it wasn't for the deal that they struck
with the MCU I mean it brought it into
the MCU and made it something different
especially after the Cataclysm event
that was the amazing spider-man films
with Andrew Garfield like those are just
those sucked at the box office or just
only Sony joints but you know like with
what spider-man I know they have their
own thing going on now but fact of the
matter is they need each other the the
other side of people saying Disney being
greedy well if you think about it it's
like I think they deserved a bigger
percentage than 5% if that's what the
actual number is 5% that's pretty low
yeah 5% of one day's grosses of one
day's grosses when the spider-man when
Spiderman far from home spider-man Home
Coming are so strongly linked and
benefits so much off of its involvement
with the MCU it arguably deserves a
bigger percentage now I could understand
the shock value of wait we had 5% now
you won 50% is pretty big well and
Marvel also wants to throw in their own
I think they also want to throw in more
resources to produce them
yes well as taking arguably a bigger cut
for doing so yeah from my understanding
from what Collider reported on their
website is that yeah one day gross from
my understandable Collider part on the
website is that they they're still in
negotiations like if this was official
we probably would have heard like
officially from both studios by now as
opposed to just Hollywood sites or movie
news sites reporting on this because
this this is nuts
I think it would be moronic it would be
so stupid
if people if Sony did not further
continue their relationship with the MCU
that would just be completely idiotic I
understand that a 50% is a much bigger
asking as opposed to 5% but I bet they
wanted more MCU involvement with the
other spider-man characters as well like
this whatever spider-verse that are
developing so what's what's up John
you leave the chat I feel naked without
you John you just abandoned us man cuz
yeah they want to co-financed the movie
too they want to do a 50/50 financing
thing especially if they want them to be
more involved too especially they want
them to be more involved see the thing
to to me is also they've had especially
after far from home a very significant
spider-man involvement and it seems like
it sets up for the future so if Sony
doesn't play with this if they didn't
play that about this like what happens
then to the future of like it doesn't
sound from the announcements of what's
coming in the next phase like spider-man
is gonna be hugely instrumental but he
also did serve as the transition point
between two phases
well spider-man and far from home is the
very first spider-man movie to ever
across a billion dollars and that's it's
a really great success because of taking
place after Avengers and game being
linked to Avengers endgame so while 50%
is a lot to ask for in I mean from from
from this complete outside perspective
without having all these details like
with none of us having the full scope
with having the full details to me
it sounds fair when you got a property
and you got two Studios who are both
reliant on this like spider-man needs
MCU more than spider-man needs Sony if
you just look at the spider-man property
well yes fifty-fifty sounds ideal and
just completely fair for the bargain
well it seems Sony would be basically
silly to not realize what an asset their
link to marble is because they would be
I think very foolish not to be very
aware that their current success of
spider-man has a huge debt of gratitude
to their agreement here yeah say that
it's only Marvel that made this happen
but I do I just read from this and this
is just my own interpretation some kind
of weird insecurity or something like
they really want to hang on to
spider-man even though like Marvel
really has been significant and
reinvigorating the character after so
needs okay yeah amazing direction and
people are chiming in st. negotiations
are still happening of course
negotiations are still happening it's
not like I guess like I said earlier
this is definitely not like something
that is completely official so I yeah
it's we have if there's been a new
counter or anything but I think I felt
like once Sony started developing more
there spider-verse like with into the
spider-verse and even though a won an
Oscar and it didn't have like anywhere
near the box of a success of any of the
solo spider-man movies or even venom for
that matter but when venom was a big box
office success I feel like this is a
fear that a lot of us were feeling Sony
could because this was always a
possibility the fact that Sony could
eventually pull out from the Marvel deal
this is a possibility like it was always
up to open for contract for
renegotiation so it wouldn't be a the
thing with Sony's history it's not a
complete surprise if they end up doing
this officially remember the day's an
MEP Amy Pascal was there and she just
said stupid [ __ ] and interviews next to
Kevin Feige what happened to those days
man
what happened to those days the Pascal
company involved with this to like I
don't I don't know who to blame for any
of these things anymore but yeah these
negotiations probably take a while
time to redraft they're probably lawyers
you know arguing about this right now
yeah this can't be the last we have
heard about it and I think that I mean
if you look at it and Marvel gets the
shaft more than Sony does because if you
look at Sony's movies of spider-man
right now they've had Nick Fury and a
couple auxilary elements they had are
obviously Tony Stark but not in a way
where they couldn't continue making the
home spider-man series without Marshall
you know like if they wouldn't have to
lose tom hollander blah blah we got mace
windu thanks buddy for the contribution
err he said what are they gonna do with
the end of far from home his identity
revealed JJJ and JD Jo Jameson in his
relationship with Michelle thrown away
with no conclusion well the report says
that they're supposed to have at least
two movies in development and possible
like for sure John watts and Tom Holland
they're supposed to have two more
spider-man movies at least the question
is now will Kevin Feige be lead producer
on those films but that does throw a
wrench in their plans I heard some thing
that they had like a 9:00 movie
spider-man plan and what they left at
the end credits the the mid-credits
scene for spider-man far from home
clearly they had huge longevity plans
for spider-man and if obviously if this
doesn't go through this throws a wrench
in the development of the MCU and
whatever timeline plan they had they're
known to adapt they've changed things
along the way
the idea of Thanos wasn't even
introduced until Avengers Assemble
so like that that wasn't even part of
their original plan to get to endgame
through this manner so it's a bummer
because clearly they had a specific plan
of what they wanted to do I think they
had a specific plan of how they wanted
this to affect the MCU but to your point
I don't think this actually means if
they don't work out a deal that we won't
see the those characters continues like
although continuing through so
definitely kit carry on yeah what
happens with MJ all that stuff it's just
you won't hear about the snap inning and
things like yeah you know which which
again wouldn't be great but I feel like
they wouldn't have to reboot again or
something like that I just I move it I
would be if it officially gets reported
that it's not happening I would I would
be pissed I will be very upset
and ungrate idea you have spider-man
homecoming which is so specifically tied
to Ironman and then even far from home
is this is so tied to Ironman and then
you got happy Hogan in there that
linkage is so vital to those stories
it's an it's a necessary part of this
specific spider-man solo franchise that
you're completely like I don't mention
Avengers Tom Vincent sorry it would it
would be a reboot it would be a reboot
like whether or not they want it to be
it would essentially be a soft reboot of
sorts it would change things yeah all
right I think we've talked this to death
is there any is there any specific
comments that you got like those those
are pretty but if you guys just chiming
in now like I've pretty much said
everything but if anyone has a specific
or unique take John will read for a
morning your comments and see and then
we're gonna move on to matrix for
support for Sam Raimi beyond the credit
we might we might finally get that
spider-man for Old Man Pete into the
frame here you know hey I mean they did
spider-verse so that's true they had
their own people all that star tech fit
[ __ ] that us so that Peter Parker gotta
know just can't acknowledge that anymore
hey spider purse and all that's really
worth is the other spider-man films are
fine but the biggest successes have been
from the MCU with spider-man so it would
they would be foolish to not make
something happen anyway yeah so there
are people who like hate Sony and people
hate busy and everyone's taking sides
right now this is this is fun this is
Hans clash we lose yeah yeah but they
are just at the end of the day there's
nothing official
so let's not entirely freak out just
yeah all right like chances are all
these people love money and they'll
figure something
don't figure out what makes the most
money that's true that's true eventually
don't worry Disney will eventually just
by Sony and everything will be fine
everything will be fine and then then
they'll buy Amazon and the boys will
come into the frame and just really
screw up the tone of everything yeah so
okay really quick onto the matrix for
that's what I'm wearing my matrix this
is the news I really wanted to talk
about and this completely overshadowed
all my thoughts the matrix for is
happening and I actually believe it
because lana wachowski actually started
talking about it and she put out a quote
about being excited to be involved in
here this basically going back through
their old ideas and working with their
friends again yes so it seems like it
will be you know heavily entrenched in
their classic mythology I I bought
tickets for the they're re-releasing the
major and this all been very
specifically planned that re-releasing
the matrix and theaters for one week I
did buy tickets matrix one matrix matrix
one at Terminator two are tied for my
top two favorite movies of all time I
feel like the ideas and concepts of
technology has evolved in yada yada yada
yada that the matrix is probably more
relevant now than it ever has been
it was very relevant then of course but
I'm curious to know mystic I put out a
poll earlier on the on our community
page going okay so who are you guys
excited yes or no or just gonna wait for
her trailer if I were to vote I would
say wait for a trailer I'm cautiously
optimistic about this though which
housekeys themselves haven't necessarily
made it that good of a movie a very long
time at least for the mainstream one
could argue about how cool it is there
of how they present their philosophies
and all those all yes and how it was
strange and then against the norm they
can be but in terms of attainable
mainstream movies they haven't really
done something that appealing what's
interesting to me about it is honestly
beyond the fact that neo and Trinity are
somehow coming back the two characters
who've case you haven't seen the matrix
it's your characters who died in the
Matrix Revolutions that why they have an
Laurence Fishburne who did survive so
I'm wondering if this is going to be an
actual part for that takes place
afterwards but then again even if the
infant if it wasn't shouldn't Morpheus
still be around yeah thanks I woke up
Trinity and welcomed me up this is also
now I mean maybe sensei it was great
yeah that's true talk to him yeah
there's something I mean it would be
very weird if he didn't come back yeah
and jada pinkett also did survive and
also and io v spin-off also they they
also what do they do they have like
different screenwriters now attached for
matrix for lana wachowski will be
writing on and she's the one who signed
on to direct there's no no way and then
Lily wachowski is there's not been any
comment on whether or not she's gonna be
directly involved although Lana's quote
does acknowledge their ideas together so
yeah I would be more if they were both
coming back I'd be more excited I'm
happy that they actually have a couple
of writers on board who are not just the
witch house keys because I feel like
that's where some of the problems went
happened with Matrix Reloaded and me
even though they were the ones who
helmed entirely the matrix I feel like
some of the prompts can't a lot of
problems can be associated with the
screenplay for Matrix Reloaded and
revolutions when you just let those
sisters go loose just like what the
hell's going on yeah there is a time and
pressure difference too because I got to
imagine that part of the reason we have
this announcement aside from the
anniversary is the key on essence there
times are different now and not just
from the way that they were different
from 1999 but there we've had the
benefit of the passage of time and with
people like the Wachowski who can be hit
or miss in terms of their reach and
their grasp when they come up with these
crazy ideas and stuff I feel like the
passage of time especially for a world
in a project like this can actually be a
nice thing especially if yeah they've
had time over the years to let some of
these ideas percolate also see what
worked and what didn't work about the
sequels because those had I would
imagine a direct pressure to be produced
quicker be more spectacular and have
probably a more difficult balance
between the ideas and how the movies are
presented they're actually some great
videos
saison The Matrix series is a whole
patrick age Willems
but what i will say too is that someone
who just said that in the comments there
pigtail talking about the cinematics
that is true if the imagine wouldn't the
visual effects for the matrix for a
groundbreaking decades ago
imagine how freaking insane they would
be today they're gonna invent a bullet
cameras that are just like you loaded a
camera into a gun to shoot it in the
middle of vision and that's yeah new
tech really this is one of those
franchises where people are like how
could they do this with a lot of people
are chiming in about this how could they
do this without with with neo and
Trinity being dead how do you do a
proper sequel that doesn't make any
sense the matrix is one of those
franchises that can figure out some
weird sci-fi [ __ ] away there we go
oh okay that makes sense sure I just go
ahead and make that part of the premise
of the movies like why are we back they
could just be the programs because neo
and Trinity are programs as well as
embodying these physical bodies but you
know they could have something to do
with that maybe they just exist within
the matrix where they don't exist within
the real world look like Zion and stuff
well the thing about The Matrix - to me
is that it is a series that has the
benefit of a lot of expansions not just
movie sequels it has like the Animatrix
it has the video games that were
actually somewhat involved I feel like
we've just had enough matrix stuff and
the mythology is rich enough the world
is broad enough that you could expand
you could do things with it and you
could make it relevant beyond just being
like we got to make that matrix money so
things like that give me just like a
cautious optimism because you say matrix
to me it's not a franchise I think duo
you could never I'm just like you have
to really think it out and do the right
thing but I think it is some place you
could go and do something both cool and
relatively and the the funny thing is
the matrix is the one franchise - that
if you wanted to call the matrix for the
matrix rebooted alright guys well this
was fun
as we've been talking I've also been
distracted by all
guys arguing in the livestream as
expected who loves Marvel who loves Sony
so keep talking with each other to keep
leaving comments are you more excited
for the matrix or all your emotions
strictly focused on this potential
spider-man news keep in mind it's not
officially confirmed from Marvel Disney
or Sony yet so yeah I think it's
important though to go to social media
and let the outcry go know let them know
hey why because they pay attention to
that and if enough people are like don't
do this which everyone is they'll
definitely be like look we got to figure
out a way to piss off too many people
you know whatever we got that second
Aladdin trailer all right guys we'll
talk with you soon and thank you to
everyone for being here thing you know
for chiming in and got to go run a
couple of personal things but much love
and keep a lookout for more uploads